what does it mean if you guys to be here
together something
I'd rather be with her than here by
myself we celebrate our show together we
did great work together and we're having
a really lovely time together and and
you know we just want to be here amongst
other creatives it's fantastic we love
it
is it really meaningful to be recognized
for your work on this show yeah you know
we don't do this for nothing you know
any any voice from the wilderness saying
you're doing alright you know it'd be
good it's good for me you know I love it
I do it for them you know I mean who's
kidding you know we can't kid ourselves
we do it for a reaction you know effect
on people it's such a great party the
champagne is flowing everybody is in
great spirits what is your favorite part
of the golden book my favorite what's
your favorite well so far we just like
seeing our friends that we can you know
be excited about their work as well
but I don't know it's early yeah you
don't know yet you know what I mean some
crazy stuff could go down he usually
does you know and how will you celebrate
yes that sounds good demand yeah
absolutely
watching something stupid any chance
we'd see you up hosting the Academy
Awards someday not a chance
I don't like being a traffic cop
you